la enfermedad pulmonar obstructiva
crónica epoc es la pérdida gradual de la
capacidad de respirar de forma eficaz
normalmente al inhalar el aire se mueve
libremente por la tráquea
y luego pasa por grandes tubos llamados
bronquios a tubos más pequeños llamados
bronquiolos
y finalmente llega a pequeños sacos
llamados alveolos
pequeños vasos sanguíneos llamados
capilares rodean a los alveolos
el oxígeno del aire que respira pasa los
capilares luego el dióxido de carbono de
su cuerpo pasa de los capilares a los
alveolos para que sus pulmones puedan
deshacerse de él al exhalar normalmente
las vías respiratorias y los alvéolos
son flexibles y elásticos al inhalar
cada saco de aire se infla como un
pequeño globo
y al exhalar los sacos se desinflan
el tabaquismo es la principal causa de
la eps y sin embargo también puede ser
causada por la exposición prolongada a
otros irritantes pulmonares como la
contaminación del aire los vapores
químicos el polvo y el humo de otras
fuentes
si usted sufre o se tiene las dos
afecciones principales que constituyen
la enfermedad enfisema y bronquitis
crónica
en el enfisema las vías respiratorias y
los alvéolos pierden su forma y se
vuelven flácidos esto hace que fluya
menos aire dentro y fuera de ellos
el enfisema destruye algunas de las
paredes de los sacos de aire lo que
genera menos sacos grandes y proporciona
menos superficie para absorber el
oxígeno del aire que respira con el
tiempo estos cambios pueden bloquear el
flujo normal de aire dando como
resultado una afección llamada
atrapamiento aéreo esto significa que
algo de aire queda atrapado en sus
pulmones al exhalar
el atrapamiento aéreo causa una afección
llamada hiper insuflación pulmonar
esto significa que sus pulmones están
excesivamente llenos de aire la hiper
insuflación pulmonar debilita el
diafragma un músculo que ayuda a
respirar esto hace que el diafragma se
aplaste
un diafragma más plano y más débil no
puede contraerse también por lo que es
más difícil respirar
los síntomas de enfisema incluyen
sibilancias falta de aliento y opresión
en el pecho
con la bronquitis crónica el daño dentro
de las vías respiratorias hace que el
revestimiento se hinche se engruesa y
produzca mucosidad se desarrolla una tos
persistente mientras el cuerpo intenta
deshacerse de la mucosidad adicional
los síntomas de la bronquitis crónica
incluyen una tos continua que produce
una gran cantidad de moco falta de
aliento e infecciones respiratorias
frecuentes
el daño causado a los pulmones por la
pose no se puede invertir y no hay cura
para la enfermedad
sin embargo el tratamiento puede
ralentizar el progreso de su enfermedad
y ayudarle a sentirse mejor
los tratamientos más frecuentes son
dejar de fumar
uso de medicamentos inhalados para abrir
las vías respiratorias y reducir la
hinchazón antibióticos para la
bronquitis causada por una infección
bacteriana
oxigenoterapia para los pacientes con ep
o se avanzada y niveles muy bajos de
oxígeno en la sangre
y cirugía como un amuleto mía o cirugía
de reducción de volumen pulmonar para
eliminar los alvéolos que no funcionan
la mejor manera de evitar la pose es no
fumar
y si ya es fumador dejar de fumar reduce
la posibilidad de desarrollar empleos y
también puede limitar su exposición a
productos químicos humos y polvos que
puedan causar
ep ose
si tiene alguna pregunta sobre la epe o
se habla con su proveedor de atención
médica